oh you got to hear this as long as i
bring up the name of matt this [ __ ]
guy last time we had him on the air
he said he was being celibate he's not
going to be with him
right you remember that yeah yeah yeah
so
uh the guys come in this morning and
said oh met some chick is offering him a
threesome
wow oh dude what happened to you being
celibate
what happened i'm i i am right now you
are yes but how'd you meet this girl
then
well i slipped one time but
that was it i don't want to threesome
with two dudes she came to me
she came to me and said look here's an
offer i'm willing to make you
if you give me this fantasy of being
with two dudes
i will give you a threesome with two
chicks let me ask you this question
okay go ahead ronnie you're [ __ ] this
girl right without
another guy involved right now yeah
right yeah obviously you're not
satisfying her well there's a lot to
think about i mean i told her i was like
well would have to be someone with a
with a smaller penis than me
yeah and how are you gonna find that
well she knows how big my penis is wait
a minute can i ask a question yes
so now that this has been proposed yeah
have you
fantasized about it uh well i've thought
about both threesomes yes and i wouldn't
say fantasize that's
what he has answered no no no no no i
wouldn't say
it's not you want to go in the bathroom
with richard
is the girl gonna give you pictures of
this guy's dick to make sure that it's
smaller than yours
no i don't want a picture of him the
first time you see his dick is going to
be in the room
and there's a lot there's a lot of
thinking about yeah like
like i said i mean i want to be in
better shape i want to have a bigger
penis
so the guy can see what's going to
happen how come you want that get a
bigger
i want to be with a woman who wants to
be with me yeah
if she wants to be with another girl
even then i got to make sure you know
like
dude when a girl says to me i want you
in the room with another guy
dude that's going to just lead to all
kind of [ __ ] trouble i mean
i'm looking for a threesome with two
girls and this is right now the proposal
i've been given and am i tossing it
around in my head
you say goodbye to that one uh thank you
that's not what you're looking for
i feel like even if i end up totally
humiliating myself in this situation
which is very likely
i'll still be able to at the end of the
night tell myself well you're still
gonna get that threesome with two girls
why would she come back well well
someone suggested to me and i i think
i'm going to go through it that
or try at least why did you get the
threesome with her and the two girls
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
going to try to go for
yeah or make her sign a contract that's
good oh yeah